well the daily wire my publication they
do an excellent job covering everything
happening down at the border chrissy
clark
he's a staff reporter at daily wire she
writes on issues of higher education
her work is also featured in the
washington free beacon federalist and
daily signal
and she has now cut a video on the
border crisis she went down to the
border to check it out christie thanks
so much for joining the show
yeah thanks for having me so why don't
you tell us about what you saw down on
the border obviously the bind
administration claims they've got this
thing under control
they say that it is not a crisis it is a
challenge but now joe biden is saying
actually it's not even a challenge
apparently he's now saying in national
interviews that this thing is beginning
to wane and that we we are now beginning
to control this thing
what is what is the evidence of that
there is no evidence that this is waning
in fact these crisis
or these migrant detention centers are
turning into an even bigger crisis right
now
i've talked to border patrol agents that
are part of the border patrol union down
there
regularly and they tell me that this
isn't getting better in fact they've
been put into facilities at this point
and they just see more and more people
there are pods that are meant for 33
people
where they're squishing 250 to 300
people into a pod meant for 33 people
and the biden administration because of
the pr disaster of 2014
they've tried to get rid of these chain
link fence by putting in plastic sheets
imagine trying to clean down a plastic
street like that's like a
you know a cover that you have in your
bathtub i don't know like
it's absolutely disgusting it's less
sanitary for these migrants
and it's kind of disturbing that an
administration would do what looks best
for
it instead of what's best for the health
and safety of children so what exactly
has the biden administration changed in
terms of policy
that has facilitated this giant border
rush because obviously
there there were migrants who were
showing up at the southern border
throughout the trump administration but
it really started to exponentially
increase directly after joe biden's
election
yeah border patrol agents told us that
it's two prong partially it's the
rhetoric
migrants have a completely different
understanding of our policy than what uh
even you know joe biden thinks that he's
saying
migrants heard when joe biden said that
we're gonna have a moratorium on
deportations they just think that they
can come here if they get here in the
first 100 days
they're here to stay they're not going
to be deported they don't have to go
through the asylum claim process they're
just going to get in here for free
so they that's what they've interpreted
it as that's
obviously wrong but that's how they hear
it and they've seen their friends or
other family members be successful at it
and so that's exactly what they think
they can do
and then the second prong is finishing
the border wall now migrants know that
they most of them come there and they
turn themselves in but it's the violent
criminals that don't want to be
apprehended by border patrol that
know that now is the time to do it while
we have a liberal administration that
doesn't want to finish the border wall
where it's really easy for them to
traverse into the country so chrissy one
of the things that joe biden
just said in an interview over the last
24 hours who's asked specifically about
his pledge
that he'd be reuniting these children
with their families and the interviewer
said um we have no evidence that a
single child has been reunited with
their family and biden said well i don't
know about that but it could be true
uh it is astonishing that he continues
to get away with with all of this
it seems like it's having some impact
even on border state democrats so mark
kelly came out after the state of the
union address or fake state of the union
address
and said pretty openly doesn't seem like
there's a border plan to me
how's this playing for democrats in
border states
i mean it's terrible for them obviously
there's there's no doubt about it but
the really sad thing is that you can't
tell whether a child's been reunited
with their
parents or not because you don't
actually know who their parents are what
i saw when i was at the border i went
down to roma texas and saw
these kids being put in rafts coming
back and forth across um and
texas state rangers told the daily wire
that this is
you these kids are just sent over and
over again they see them every other
week
they go through the entire process
because it's twelve thousand dollars to
get smuggled in by the
cartel so if a parent can't pay the
twelve thousand dollars to send their
kid across
they'll just send the kid across back
and forth and back and forth and back
and forth until they've
you know made what they would think to
be twelve thousand dollars to get the
kid across
so you don't actually know if that kid
belongs to the parent that they come
into a facility with
so no i don't i don't know how they
would possibly think that they're
reuniting
with a family member when we don't even
know who their family member really is
so is there any path forward out of this
or is this just going to continue
at this level i'd import infinite
because it doesn't seem like they're
taking any sort of mitigating measures
at this point
no i mean border patrol agents just say
that the best thing that they could do
right now to
kind of slow the wave and make things
more livable for migrants that are in
these facilities is to allow
deportations
and to finish the wall because finishing
the wall is not just for
the understand or for the betterment of
border patrol agents and their safety
it's also very important to keep a
migrant safe if you don't want a 12 year
old crossing the border
with 20 pounds of drugs strapped to
their back because they can't afford to
come into the united states
then finish the border wall because
that's the only way you're going to fix
it
so that was the those were the two
solutions what is morale like among the
members of border patrol so you say you
speak to them all the time
i mean we've seen that when it comes to
policing in the united states a lot of
cops are just laying down their badges
and saying i'm not doing this they're
looking for early retirement what's the
morale like with border patrol right now
a lot of them have been been in this
situation for so long that
no it's not necessarily a unique crisis
to the biden administration it's just
this massive massive
influx that makes them exhausted i saw
them working double shifts
i could not believe how many hours these
people work
it's insane they're not necessarily in
low morale
um but they have a lot of um what's the
word i'm looking
they're just very motivated to showcase
this problem they really want people to
know
because they want their workload lifted
um not a lot
but you know they want it lifted back to
how it normally is
chrissy clark staff reporter at the
daily wire go check out the new video
she just cut over at daily wire
on the situation the world chris we
appreciate your time
thank you we're in a battle for the
culture and for our values
like and subscribe to help keep our
videos on the front line of the fight
and top of your feet